notre communauté autochtone de 400
résidents peu se souviennent de l'époque
où l'eau courante pouvait être consommés
en toute sécurité à neige qantara dans
le nord de l'ontario l'avis d'ébullition
de l'eau est entrée en vigueur en 1995
et n'a jamais été levée depuis
services aux autochtones canada espère
que cet avis sera levé avant que la
communauté franchesse un autre triste
record pour cela at avoir annoncé un
investissement pour moderniser l'usiné
de traitement de l'eau de neige cantagal
en 2016 mais des problèmes avec le
fournisseur ont entre autres ralenti ce
processus et des tests doivent encore
être effectuées avant de pouvoir lever
officiellement l'avis d'ébullition à
cela s'ajoute aussi la confiance qu'il
faudra rétablir
avec ce triste record 10 mille jours
sans eau potable soit 27 ans et 4 mois
c'est toute une génération qui a grandi
en se méfiant de l'eau une ou non
potable qui a aussi entraîné des
problèmes de peau chez certains membres
de la communauté en plus de bouleverser
leur vie quotidienne des
changements sociaux
[Musique]
au canada 34 avis d'ébullition de l'eau
sont toujours en vigueur dans les
communautés autochtones dont la grande
majorité en ontario un échec en daga
services aux autochtones canada espère
pouvoir lever l'avis d'ébullition de
l'eau d'ici l'automne prochain mais
plusieurs membres de la communauté sont
sceptiques ce n'est pas la première fois
qu'ils entendent ce genre de promesse
ici ayadi fort radio-canada ça brille
[Musique]